i want to talk to you for a second about
the fast and furious films you've been
in so many of these films and
um i this is a true story uh absolutely
true
two days ago i watched fast and furious
seven
uh with a friend of mine uh my head
writer matt we watched it again
because that the stunts are just so
insane and i just keep thinking i don't
know how they
top this because every time i watch the
movie i mean in the last movie
you guys were driving cars from one
tower into another tower
into another tower you were jumping out
of airplanes
in cars uh it gets to the point where i
think
what what can you do that hasn't been
done already with these cars
listen i can't give it away but conan i
can promise you
that we are doing something that has
never been
done so june 25th is the final date
because of course we got pushed back
sure as a covid and theaters not being
open right but on june 25th everyone
will have their shot at going to see
yet another like extremely
ridiculous ludicrous fast and furious
movie
yes part of the theater experience yeah
i i i go
i know stencil uh and i swear to god i
love that everything has to involve a
car
like if you guys have to break into a
closet you've got to drive into the
closet
in a car you everything has to happen in
a
car if you have to pretend to be waiters
to get the bad guys
you dress up as waiters and you drive
into the front of the window of the
restaurant in a car
i love it facts man you know what's even
crazier
a lot of people don't notice but every
single fast and furious i bought
one of the cars that was in the movie
i've heard this i've heard this
except for the ones where we shot in
london where the steering wheel was on
the other
side of the car
because i didn't want to deal with that
yeah all of the other ones i bought cars
as a matter of fact there was one from
too fast too furious
if we have real fast and furious fans on
here there was a dodge
truck that had like a louis vuitton wrap
on it
i have it i have it right here this
is the car and it's a truck
dodge truck wrapped with louis
vuitton insignias on it and you
bought this car and you drove it around
how did that go
how was the experience of driving this
car around it didn't go well
at all i drove it for one day and
everyone
in the city of atlanta georgia knew it
was me i had a tailgating party like
everyone was behind me and has literally
never wanted to drive this car ever
again so i gave it away to my friend at
the time so that he
could have people follow him all the
damn time right now all i drive is
my 93 acura legend because this is the
exact opposite
of having a louis vuitton wrapped uh
truck
okay so you drive a 93 acura legend
you man ludacris drives around in a 93
acura legend so this is a car that i had
before
i was commercially successful as a
rapper one of my favorite cars has over
250 000 miles on it
still drive it to this day it's the car
that i drive the most
you know what i had i had before i got
on television i had a 92
ford taurus what no don't
give me attitude that's the hell did you
fit in that car like you're too tall
no no i caught you i cut a hole i cut a
hole in the roof
you know and uh but i would drive around
this car
ladies love a 92 ford taurus
okay this thing was a magnet all right
they didn't even care who was driving
they were like whoever's in that ford
taurus
i've got to be with that man and the
same way i said i took advantage of
every room in my house you took
advantage of every seat in the four
tours is what you're trying to tell
yes exactly exactly yeah i mean this was
and i could it was insanity
and i kept that car i still have that
car to this day
because it brings back so many wild
memories
but one day me and you have to drive our
acura legend and four taurus around the
town
just to do it okay let's do it this is
what i want to do
i want us to do that but first i want
your acura and my tourists to be wrapped
in the louis vuitton logo
then we drive them around now i got to
ask you about this
you uh got a car
that bounces and we have actually some
footage of you
bouncing in this car let's show the
footage and then i want you to explain
why let's take a look
that's not me doing that baby that's the
car doing that okay
why do you need a car it does that what
is it
what does it do for you listen man this
is a very good reason
like most of the time we listen to music
we're in the car right right
right you need a car to dance
with you when you dance
now you're laughing but this is true man
who the hell wants a car
if you're dancing in the car staying
still yep come on conan that's right
that makes no sense whatsoever you're
right
your car needs to be able to dance with
you
i can see that yeah think about your
ford taurus if it was able to bounce the
same way
that that mercedes maybach did yeah it
had been a whole different situation and
your car would have been doing most of
the work with the women that you were
with in the four tours you wouldn't have
had to do much
guess what i'm told i didn't do much oh
i get a lot of complaints
back in the day a lot of complaints i
just i tend to lay perfectly still
um
the car was the only thing that moved i
look i'm very shy
and i don't like to move
that's uh by the way what did you think
of my dancing chris what's
going on terrible terrible terrible yeah
you're a blatantly honest guy so i'm
sure you wouldn't mind me being
blatantly honest back to you
your dancing is terrible what are you
talking about i'm exploring the space
around here no no
you need a car that bounces man
immediately
all right if you ever go to wimbledon or
the masters make sure you don't dance in
the stands i know
i will i will i will i'll be you're
right this is good
you know what you've been a good friend
of me over the years and you being
honest with me i really appreciate it
because i think a lot of people
would have said conan you're the best
dancer i've ever seen you cut right to
the chase and you saved me
you you kept me humble and i thank you
no for sure 100
sometimes certain things just aren't for
us man you need to concentrate on other
things
yeah okay please tell me what that is
because i've never figured it out